oh
guys what the hell
are you doing guys i like how they're
like don't touch her don't touch her
grinding day pelvis like where are you
trying to go where are you trying to go
it's like bro
right here it's terrifying i'm not gonna
lie to you man i remember being 17
and then hanging out with a group of
dudes and they would like yell from
people
from like a car i'm like what are y'all
doing i was so
embarrassed every time they did that i'm
like do you not see how cringy you guys
are like
i was like man i'm glad i don't i don't
i stopped hanging out with those people
shortly after but i
always thought that kind of behavior was
cringing yelling at people or trying to
follow people who've already like
clearly said they want to get away from
you if you want to go to the lady be
like hey what's up
and then just walk away okay but don't
be persistent on some [ __ ] where you
clearly can tell she's uncomfortable
and especially if there's a group of
guys and you surround her like bruh
like well look i wanna i really wanna
know how does it work in your head
how does that work in your head that you
think that she's gonna say yes
and you would want someone that would be
pressured to say yes like that
like like that i can assure you people
have said yes of course
and i can assure you that it wasn't the
right frame of mind to be able to say of
course yeah
like but how as a guy how do you
that's okay to you yeah yeah yeah yeah
what what
what the [ __ ] are you doing
and then if a guy interjects you're
gonna jump in oh you're being a sip
you're trying to be a captain
captain stable that's not what the
captain's about she's trying to pay for
her gas
and you guys are surrounding her and
keeping her from going where she needs
to go
no trash that that bro you know this is
this is picking on the defenseless
real talk absolutely you guys are
clearly bigger stronger than her and
you're surrounded in the cost of
a woman while she's just trying to go
for a gas it's late at night
and there's like 20 of you muff banging
your chest and [ __ ]
in that situation it's not because she's
smiling that she feels comfortable
let's be honest about something all
right she's probably going to be smiling
and be like
guys stop is that that don't mean she's
comfortable or not afraid of y'all
the smile don't let that smile fool you
don't think that that smile
is gonna and i'm not going to say this
whole thing imagine if it was your
sister or your mother it's like
listen ladies are not deserving of
empathy only if you can think of a
relation that has anything to do with
them
thank you that's like so stupid thank
you all right if i see an old lady and
she's struggling with her grocery bags
and it drops i wouldn't be like hey cyan
got a grandma
it's it's somebody who's in need like
not everything has to be linked back to
family
at the end of the day what it comes down
to is this is super trash behavior
and yo listen if cops were involved i
wouldn't be mad someone's just trying to
go about our business and you
the person i've seen this happen in so
many foreign countries too
and it gets worse over there because
policing is even less enforced
so nah i'm not with this when someone
sent me this i was just like man the
people involved are garbage
and for them to film this and think this
is hilarious it's crazy ain't nobody
doing nothing
hey man don't touch her don't touch her
don't touch her but you block her path
and you stick your pelvis into her
this is definitely going to get sweated
around this mouth
yeah you came in a circle you better get
it too
you see what he said you came to a
circle for a pimp you think this is
pimping
that's not seven dudes surrounded one
girl in a dress is trying to pay for a
guess
you guys are super desperate zero
discipline
you look like low lifes that ain't it
and then mom's gonna be like
i would never let my girl leave the home
in an outfit like that she got a dress
that's almost close to her ankles like
what is he
talking about
i would have made it through she made it
through she broke through the barrier
hold on it's a there's some pressure
being applied around here it's a real
pimping though
i don't know act like she never been
caught before you guys are degeneres
that's just whack this right here it
ain't it you could do better than that
you know what bothers me bro is that our
degeneracy as black folks it seems to
always be broadcasted so loudly like
websites are world star
yeah you know like when i go to foreign
countries and i see the same degeneracy
they don't often record it or have
platforms you know what i mean
we have world star hip-hop just for that
the showcase the ratchet three
bruh
that's game that's what it is there is
nothing to say
there's nothing to say that's what it is
in some areas bro that's what it is in
some areas and like
you know when women say stuff like yo
i'm afraid to go to the gas station at
night like
i get it i get it because i've seen this
i've seen this happen in front of me
where there's like 20 dudes
and then people like abba what are you
gonna do i'm not gonna do [ __ ] you you
crazy
if you think i'm gonna go to a rabid
group of men who are
accosting a lady there's 20 of them or
15 or 10 of them and you think i'm i'm a
bro i get to live too okay because men
don't take kindly
when other men interfere now it doesn't
mean that i want to be silent on this
issue but it's also a matter of like
what you expect mom to do you think i
carry weapons with me at all times you
think i'm uh
i'm no you're crazy i've seen stuff and
i'm like whoa
you don't carry weapons with you at all
times
you got a bazooka and nobody does okay
then well you going with a shootout with
nobody
exactly so there's not about having
weapons i know i know what you're saying
even if you did have a weapon oh even if
you did
you put yourself in a situation you
don't want to be put in here man
i'll keep it a buck with y'all and
people like yo what can you do i don't
know i can't do
it this is the only thing i can do
there's one disabout this kind of stuff
when i see it
uh you know and then after that is just
make sure the people around me are not
engaged in that kind of behavior
you know the people who i can't
influence and have a uh you know a talk
with
but if you think i'm gonna jump in front
of 15 dudes you're crazy
but again what happened to y'all's not
right man my cousins told me stories
when she was traveling the world bro
that's like that's like levels of
problems here you have the behavior
you have the fact that it's got
broadcasted that nobody's saying [ __ ]
that the bystanders are engaging in that
what did your cousin say nah man she
just had to deal with it so much
when she traveled like into certain
places especially when people have a
little bit of liquor in them and it's
like that night time man
degenerates come out in full force so i
don't think i have much more point of
commentary to add to this it's just it's
unfortunate this stuff happens
i'm not for it other than calling it out
when i see it within the people who are
around me there's nothing much
because of my focus i kick it with i
spend time we'll never do stuff like
this
oh and i would call i will i will
quickly call a mother
if you do something like yo what the
[ __ ] are you doing but even in smaller
doses i don't even see anything like it
see no
because oftentimes you know if you do a
little bit of something then it can
progress somehow
i'm not even seeing that so that's why
it's tough for me because it's just one
of those things where i'm like yo
other than doing this video yeah what
can you do genuine question what can you
do
exactly you know so i just want to make
that clear it's not because people are
maybe silent
or not acting in that moment that people
don't care it's also just a matter like
you think it's dangerous for you it's
also dangerous for us you know
and at the end of the day it's like man
you know and i think about this with all
conflicts like uh
whenever there's something that had to
happen with the cops like in the the
people said like
why didn't the bystander didn't do
anything they're cops what do you want
to do
what can i do as a bystander he's
willingly putting his knee on what makes
you think he's not going to want to
shoot me
like there's nothing much more that i
can do i've seen dudes knock down those
situations beaten
kicked in the head while they're
non-conscious i've seen that happen so
many times people die
yeah happens like that all the time you
try to go and protect a girl and they
murk you because they're not gonna beat
on her like that
so generally they don't beat on him much
more aggressively to release their anger
bro i've seen the oh i've gone on to
nightclubs and be like what is y'all
doing
so you know it's tough it's one of those
things where it's like
you kind of feel pearless in that moment
and there's a difference between being
brave and being stupid the end of the
day i got responsibilities of family i
got to take care of i can't afford to
jump in but i've seen this stuff in
front of me and i'm like damn and i feel
for the person i can't imagine what it's
like so
well that's my thoughts on that anything
else you want to add you being
a bouncer no that's just dumb yeah well
[ __ ] like that had pencil at the club i
was like
i have to step in as a bouncer right
right as a bouncer
like i remember all right if you guys
want to hear this story it'll be on the
patreon
remember this one time yo i remember
story time
story time was
[Music]
foreign